"Прибрати ТЦК з вулиць", вдосконалити мобілізацію і цифровізувати армію.
Цього, за словами "слуг народу" і міноборони, дозволить досягти електронний реєстр військовозобов'язаних.
Верховна Рада ухвалила відповідний закон.
Згідно з ним, міноборони отримає дані про громадян віком від 17 до 60 років,
що містяться у різних державних реєстрах: податкової, мін'юсту, міністерства охорони здоров'я,
ЦВК, Державної міграційної служби та інших відомств.
Перша і головна мета полягає в тому, щоб у Генерального штабу Міністерства оборони
було розуміння щодо мобілізаційних ресурсів в державі,
відповідно до яких будуть створюватись мобілізаційні резерви
для здійснення ротацій тих, хто перебуває в зоні бойових дій
від початку широкомасштабного вторгнення.
Роботу електронного реєстру під назвою "Оберіг" запустили в Україні з минулого року, але не на повну.
Доступ до нього мають ТЦК.
Тепер в "Оберіг" надійде ще більше даних з державних реєстрів.
Реєстр військовозобов'язаних, призовників і резервістів наповнюється даними військовозобов'язаних,
має ключові обміни з державними реєстрами в режимі реального часу.
Наповнений на 88 процентів.
Верифікація майже завершилася.
Як інструмент для роботи з військовозобов'язаними,
для направлення повісток, для того, щоб вести облік, реєстр є повністю робочим інструментом.
Законопроєкт про реєстр військовозобов'язаних ще має підписати президент України.
Коли реєстр остаточно запрацює, усі військовозобов'язані,
резервісти й призовники матимуть свій електронний кабінет.
Туди "підтягнуться" їхні персональні дані.
Зокрема, сімейний стан, місце роботи, картка платника податків.
А також номери телефонів, адреси електронної пошти,
дані про володіння іноземними мовами, документи на зброю,
водійське посвідчення й навіть відцифрований образ обличчя.
У міноборони наголошують: усі ці дані потрібні для того, щоб налагодити процес мобілізації.
Зокрема, реєстр запустить "розумний рекрутинг" до війська.
Реєстр матиме утилітарну функцію щодо формування шорт-листів,
на підставі яких рекрутингові інституції міністерства оборони,
які матимуть доступ, зможуть маршрутизувати людей більш фахово.
Для того, щоб ми могли визначити і запропонувати військовозобов'язаному
таке місце в збройних силах або силах оборони, найбільш круте, яке розкриє його навички.
Завдяки електронному реєстру документи, які ТЦК зберігали в "папках",
перейдуть у цифровий формат. Наприклад, якщо військовозобов'язаний одружиться,
інформація про це автоматично надійде в реєстр.
Також ТЦК зможе автоматично за запитом перевірити, чи дійсно військовозобов'язаний
навчається в університеті на денній формі
й має право на відстрочку - довідку з місця навчання
не потрібно буде приносити особисто.
У міноборони запевняють: цифровізація допоможе боротися з корупцією в ТЦК,
зменшить черги, бюрократичну тяганину й випадки повторного вручення повісток.
Ми зможемо зменшити кількість помилково надісланих повісток.
Тобто люди отримуватимуть повістки цільовим чином, не буде жодних помилок.
Ми зможемо направити саме тому військовозобов'язаному, який є нашою цільовою аудиторією.
Утім, отримувати згоду на зберігання й обробку цих даних від самих військовозобов'язаних закон не вимагає.
Щодо цієї норми закону висловило застереження Головне науково-експертне управління Апарату Верховної Ради,
адже вона може порушити норми Конституції про права громадян і захист конфіденційних даних.
З моєї точки зору, це пряме порушення чинного закону про захист персональних даних,
і я не виключаю, що це може спричинити судові позови проти,
в такому випадку проти власника даних - міністерства оборони через достатньо неякісно
виписану нормативну пропозицію, цю норму в законопроєкті.
Виконавчий директор Української Гельсінської спілки Олександр Павліченко також застерігає:
єдиний реєстр буде досить вразливою базою даних.
Якщо її вдасться зламати, до рук зловмисників може потрапити особиста,
зокрема, фінансова інформація десятків тисяч людей.
Тут є питання взагалі, скажімо, доречності створення такої надмірної за обсягом бази даних,
і тут так само виникає питання належного захисту цієї бази даних,
щоб у нас не були такі випадки, як, наприклад, зі зламом того ж самого серверу "Київстару".
Водночас хоча дані військовозобов'язаних зберігатимуться в електронному форматі,
про електронні повістки поки не йдеться.